katharina essberger brenscheidt wollte
etwas für die umwelt tun seit 2013 und
die wuppertalerin ökostrom vom
energiehändler stromio der versprach
besonders günstige konditionen
doch ende dezember 2021 erhöhte stromio
die preise von 33 auf 42 cent je
kilowattstunde und kurz danach lieferte
stromio plötzlich gar nicht mehr ich war
schockiert und mir war dann klar ich
rutsche in die grundversorgung bin dann
auf der seite der wsw gegangen traute
meinen augen nicht die wsw die
wuppertaler stadtwerke sind in der
region der grundversorger wem die billig
konkurrenz kündigt landet zwangsweise
bei der wsw knapp 83 cent verlangen die
je kilowattstunde von neukunden
es ist eine bodenlose frechheit es ist
absolut unfair den verbrauchern
gegenüber die keine möglichkeit haben
sich dagegen zu wehren die
grundversorger haben hier ganz klar ihre
position als grundversorger schamlos
ausgenutzt haben die stadtwerke auf dem
rücken der kunden tatsächlich kasse
gemacht fest steht viele grundversorger
kassierten zum jahreswechsel von
neukunden saftige aufschläge
beispiele für extreme preissteigerungen
bei den stadtwerken vor zahlen zahlten
bestandskunden für strom nur 32 cent pro
kilowattstunde neukunden 107 stadtwerke
düren bestandskunden 34 cent neukunden
99 cent
hunderttausende stromkunden in ganz
deutschland sind betroffen
verbraucherschützer haben einige
grundversorger bereits abgemahnt
bereiten klagen vor wir halten da für
unzulässig dass neukunden die vom
discounter jetzt wieder zurückfallen in
die grundversorgung als kunden zweiter
klasse behandelt werden das ist eine
diskriminierung der wettbewerb soll
diskriminierungsfrei sein grundversorger
dürfen ihre marktbeherrschende stellung
hier nicht ausnutzen wir bitten die
grundversorger um stellungnahmen die
stadtwerke wuppertal düren und pforzheim
behaupten die preise seien
gerechtfertigt für die unerwarteten
neukunden habe man kurzfristig strom zu
höchstpreisen an den börsen beschaffen
müssen
energie handelsexperte marco wünsch hält
das für vorgeschoben
er hat die beschaffungspreise stets im
blick im dezember zahlten die versorger
im großhandel 25 bis 30 cent pro
kilowattstunde strom dazu kommen umlagen
steuern und netzentgelte in höhe von
rund 20 cent wenn man das zusammen
addiert kommt man auf einen preis den
man seinen endkunden in rechnung stellen
muss in höhe von 45 bis 50 cent pro
kilowattstunde mit strompreisen deutlich
über 50 cent würden die grundversorger
gewinne machen so hoch wie noch nie
dazu kann ich nur sagen dass die preise
wenn man sich die kosten komponenten
anguckt dass sich die preise in der höhe
nicht nachvollziehen kann preise von 80
90 cent ist das preishoch aus übersicht
ich glaube da haben wir behörden in
deutschland das bundeskartellamt die
bundesnetzagentur die sich das ganz
genau anschauen und die werden das dann
feststellen müssen denn auch beim
gaspreis wissen die grundversorger ihre
macht zu nutzen
experten halten maximal 18 cent pro
kilowattstunde für akzeptabel aber die
stadtwerke pforzheim verlangten zum
jahreswechsel 14 cent für altkunden
satte 41 cent für neukunden die
wuppertaler stadtwerke 18 altkunden und
34 cent neukunden
doppelte und dreifache strom und
gaspreise aber hält markus adam jurist
beim hamburger ökostromanbieter
lichtblick für bucher das sind natürlich
ganz bedenklich vorgänger weil man hier
schon daran denken muss liegt hier
möglicherweise in einzelfällen ein
ausnutzen einer zwangslage vor dann
könnte das in der tat strafrechtlich
relevant sein das ist der bug paragraf
aus dem strafgesetzbuch das kann in
einzelfällen der fall sein zuständig für
die preiskontrolle der grundversorger
sind die kartellbehörden
das landeskartellamt nrw teilt auch
frontal anfrage mit es bestehe zitat
derzeit keine notwendigkeit
kartellrechtlicher konsequenzen
die kartellbehörde baden württemberg
willst weil die rekordpreise in
pforzheim überprüfen hält aber zitat
eine preisspanne in der grund
ersatzversorgung nicht für grundsätzlich
unzulässig
der vorsitzende der monopolkommission
und berater der bundesregierung
professor jürgen kühling hält dagegen
und fordert strengere kontrollen der
kartellwächter
ja die drei spaltung geben durchaus
anlass zur sorge wenn man sieht dass zum
teil preisaufschläge bis zu 185 prozent
auf die vergleichbaren preise gemacht
werden dann stellt man sich schon die
frage ob hier nicht möglicherweise preis
höhen missbräuche vorliegen es kommt
darauf an dass die landes kartellämter
tätig werden und das tun sie
offensichtlich bislang nicht und das
muss sich dringend ändern
hohe energiepreise treffen vor allem
einkommensschwache haushalte
zwar will die bundesregierung den
700.000 wohngeldbeziehern einmalig einen
zuschuss von 135 euro in single haushalt
zahlen ob das reicht bezweifeln
sozialverbände dazu kommt ein wechsel
vom teuren grundversorger zum billigeren
anbieter scheitert bei menschen mit
wenig geld oft an schlechter bonität das
sei sozial ungerecht das sind diejenigen
die sowieso probleme haben die
möglicherweise nicht schnell neue
verträge abschließen können also
diejenigen die auf jeden cent achten
müssen und wie auch insofern ist aus
meiner sicht hier dringend geboten dass
eine genaue kontrolle erfolgt die
stadtwerke weisen das von sich und sehen
allein die verantwortung bei den billig
an dann wie die grün weltgruppe mit
ihrer marke stromio die habe ihren
kunden unhaltbare versprechen gemacht
und die aufsichtsbehörde die
bundesnetzagentur habe dabei zugeschaut
die freien energiediscounter die können
anscheinend in wildwest manier ihr
geschäft betreiben hier läuft doch
irgendwas schief und jetzt auf die
grundversorger einzuschlagen also das
schlägt eigentlich denn fass den boden
aus die bundesnetzagentur unternimmt
nichts letztendlich die energie
vertriebe besser zu beaufsichtigen
warum warnt die bundesnetzagentur kunden
nicht vor billiganbietern die ihr
geschäft offenbar nicht im griff haben
unsere konkrete nachfrage dazu
beantwortet die behörde nicht und teilte
nur mit zitat
wir bitten um verständnis dass wir uns
zu etwaigen laufenden prüfungen nicht
äußern
katharina essberger brenscheidt hatte
ökostrom bestellt so preiswert wie
möglich musste dann den teuren
grundversorger tarif zahlen weil der
billigste anbieter stromio ihr ohne
vorwarnung gekündigt hat der ist nicht
zum interview bereit wir stehen vor
verschlossenen türen schriftlich teilt
der discounter sein bedauern mit und
bittet auch um verständnis die
geschasste kundinnen dagegen fordert
aufklärung
ich erwarte von den ministerien und der
politik dass sie entsprechend
regulierend eingreifen wer soll denn
preise jenseits von 80 cent bis zu einem
euro und darüber an strom überhaupt noch
bezahlen können die bundesregierung will
drastische preissprünge ab dem sommer
verbieten wie genau verrät sie nicht
auch nicht wie sie kunden wie katharina
essberger brenscheidt besser schützen
will vor windigen geschäften der
billiganbieter